have you ever walked into a home that
feels like it's straight out of the
Luxury magazine every detail
meticulously chosen every corner exuding
Elegance today I'm excited to share
seven architectural details that will
turn your home into a masterpiece
without breaking the bank whether you're
planning to rebuild renovate or simply
upgrade your space these transformative
tips are about to redefine what you call
home sweet home be sure to pay close
attention hidden throughout this video
is secret link to my entire
architectural filing system it's 100%
free just for you it's a completely free
tool that will revolutionize your
project organization and branding with
branding being number seven on this list
now let's start with the heart of every
home the kitchen we all know it's where
memories are made it's where na makes
the Noy it's where bka makes the
Bava baklava but beyond colors and
textures in the kitchen it's the details
that truly truly matter for instance
have you ever considered the benchtop
edging profile take for example the most
common Choice the basic pencil round
Edge it's functional it's safe but it's
also very boring it doesn't quite evoke
that wow factor we're aiming for with
multiple alternatives for every
architectural style let's explore a
contemporary favorite of line the shark
noose profile notice how it tapers at
the Top This Small Change Is anything
but order AR the Shar noose profile
instantly grabs your attention it adds a
touch of sophistication and uniqueness
to your kitchen it's a subtle yet
striking detail that guests won't be
able to ignore which in turn instantly
adds value to your home but here's the
beauty of it making this change is cost
neutral when you're already investing
into a kitchen you want to invest into
these details it's a high value lowcost
choice and that is exactly what this
video is about now let's talk about a
design element that often often goes
unnoticed but can transform your entire
living space we're talking about
skirting boards when it comes to
Interior Design it's not just about
what's at eye level it's also about all
the little details that connect
everything seamlessly have you ever
walked into a room with beautiful
hardwood floors only to be met with a
skirting that just doesn't match it's a
common oversight but here's the thing
skirting plays a significant role in the
overall Aesthetics of the space
mismatched or cheap skirtings can
disrupt the harmony of your entire H so
let's consider an alternative matching
your skirtings with your hardwood floors
it's a subtle yet impactful design
Choice when the skirting seamlessly
flows from the floor it creates a sense
of continuous elegance and
sophistication if you're wondering does
matching the skirtings break the bank
well the good news is no it does not but
it is a little bit more expensive in my
opinion the added value to your home's
Aesthetics is well worth the invest ment
now did you spot that QR code behind me
scan it for your free access to my
comprehensive architectural filing
system if you're on your phone I've
buried the link at the very bottom of
the description let's move on to ceiling
Heights and ceiling Heights generally
speaking are either 2.4 or 8T in most
homes it meets the building code
requirements sure but it often feels a
little bit claustrophobic now imagine
stepping into a room with ceiling
Heights of 2.7 M or 9 ft it's still
Within a reasonable budget for most
projects but it creates an immediate
sense of spaciousness this extra height
can open up a room and make it feel so
much more inviting here's where things
get really exciting if you're looking
for a truly premium ceiling height
consider going to 3 m or 10 ft this is a
game Cher for architectural homes it
creates an incredibly luxurious and
spacious Ambience of course if you're
starting with 2.4 M ceilings and jumping
to 3 m this can be expensive so the key
is to find the middle ground that suits
your budget whilst optimizing the sense
of space if you're concerned about the
cost it isn't something that only adds
value to your home but it also enhances
the quality of life in my opinion that
is worth every scent now you've probably
walked into a well-designed room before
only to have your eyes immediately drawn
to an exposed air conditioning unit on
the wall it's a common site in many
homes and many spaces but it's a big no
no in the premium world of design let me
show you the magic of concealing
Services imagine that same room with the
air conditioning unit discreetly tucked
away inside a built and wall or a
bulkhead it's no longer an eyesa it's
part of the design it has been truly
considered as a residential example
imagine your bedroom that this air
conditioning unit was concealed above
your bedroom robe this space is often
left empty but it could be used for so
many more creative things simply
installing the air conditioning unit
inside the bulkhead and creating a
screen in the wall is simple practical
and Architectural the screen can be
anything as well don't get me wrong it
doesn't have to be expensive it can be a
bit of Timber plaster board or you can
even take abducted AC vent and plaster
it in it just has to be enough to let
the air out if you're wondering about
the cost again this is good news that
concealing Services doesn't have to
break the bank it's a smart design
choice and making the most of the spaces
you already have let's continue by
addressing a common challenge in
architect design indoor and outdoor
connection more often than not we find
rooms with an indoor and outdoor
connection but the challenge is there is
a physical barrier either with a track
or some form of Step most of us already
have a glass sliding door that leads to
their backyard but here's the game Cher
instead of a traditional raised track
that you have to step over the sliding
door can actually be dropped into the
structure of your building with this
small but architectural design
adjustment you can create a level
transition between the indoors and the
outdoors it removes the physical and
mental barrier that connects us to
Mother Nature this architectural detail
costs little more than standard practice
it's something you'll experience as an
unexplainable love for your home if we
acknowledge that lighting isn't just
about visibility it can be about
creating atmosphere we can do so much
more if you've ever walk into a room
with harsh clinical lighting it can feel
cold and unwelcoming I know I definitely
have and it really sucks now picture
that same room with warm and inviting
lighting something similar to the lights
behind me right now it changes the
entire mood it makes the space feel cozy
and comfortable the secret is in the
color and temperature of the lighting a
3,000 Calin warm light emits a natural
comforting glow on the other hand a
6,000 Calin daylight white is clinical
harsh and unwelcoming here's where it
gets exciting again because everyone
loves loves a little bit of clever Tech
with smart bulbs and control systems you
can have the best of both worlds set
your lights to Bright and white during
the day for productivity and shift to
warm whites in the evening for
relaxation and mood lighting doesn't
have to be an expensive addition you can
start by selecting the right bulbs and
fixtures to achieve the desired effect
if you want to go further and explore
smart lighting it's a cost-effective
investment into your home's Ambience all
of which can be installed
retrospectively and as this video goes
live on a Friday afternoon you can take
the weekend to test change your Globes
and let me know in the comments down
below how much of a difference this has
made to your home finally think about
your favorite Brands they're consistent
recognizable and make you feel a certain
way your home can and should do the same
let's start with the basics naming your
home just like a brand needs a name your
home should have one too it's a simple
yet powerful way to create identity for
your spaces after that you can extend
your branding to various elements
throughout your home imagine your letter
box text matches that of your doorbell
which matches your floor mats it's a
cohesive visual identity that sets the
scene for what's inside changing the
fonts on all of these items literally
costs nothing except a little bit of
patience and a little bit of time yet it
can completely transform your home's
visual identity if you need help
branding your home I've developed a
brand building guide it's an incredibly
versatile tool that can easily be
customized to match your Unique Style
and identity whether it's for your home
or even a business it should be your
first point of call before making any
creative decision I've linked it in the
description down below to recap number
one pick a bench toop profile that is
striking number two stop picking cheap
and nasty skirtings number three your
ceiling Heights really do matter number
four hide those ugly services please
number five drop those door tracks into
the structure and forget about them
number six add warmth to your home via
mood lighting and finally number seven
brand your home anyway that's all from
me team if you've enjoyed this video
consider subscribing for new content
weekly